good afternoon everybody i'm myron
martin the president
and ceo of the smith center it's well
it's a wonderful to welcome you
here to this place that's been closed
for the last 488 days so
welcome back uh we can't wait to open
this fall september
and get started again i'm also happy to
say that
because today is all about vaccinations
many
of our patrons tell us that they have
already been vaccinated
and can't wait to get back in this place
to be inspired by the arts
but i'm here today to introduce our
great governor
with all of his news today that you're
waiting to hear so ladies and gentlemen
please help me welcome
the governor of nevada steve's
thank you thank you so much appreciate
it thanks myron i appreciate that
introduction and if you have not been
here
for a show at the smith center you've
got to do it it's absolutely amazing
it's a tremendous venue
i know my wife loves to come down here
unfortunately we haven't been able to
come as much as we used to
but it is a tremendous place to come and
visit and see uh
a show and be entertained uh thank uh
nevadans for getting vaccinated and
helping protect our economy
i know we've got some of you here today
and it's an exciting time for us
and you really don't want to listen to
me so we're going to get right to the
meat of the program that we have here
the smith center is an invaluable part
of our community
and we look forward to many more vibrant
celebrations here
with the arts and our talented
entertainers in the very near
future vax nevada days are a celebration
of all that cobit 19 vaccination enables
us to do
like attending live arts performances
excuse me and to celebrate everyday
nevadans who are protecting themselves
and helping make the community strong
and safe again before we get to today's
winners
i'd like to provide an announcement on
how we are continuing our efforts to
ensure that all
eligible nevadans have access to the
covid19 vaccines
they are free they are safe and they are
effective
and they are available to nevadans over
the age of 12 years old
just this morning i had the opportunity
with secretary
becerra united states secretary of
health and human services
to visit the fema employees and
volunteers in southern nevada
who are part of the federal surge team
that we have asked to come into nevada
and help us
with our vaccination efforts these surge
teams are here at my request
to help our efforts in southern nevada
we are continuing to see an
increase in cases and hospitalizations
of unvaccinated nevadans driven
primarily
by the delta variant and i want to
emphasize one more the hospitalizations
the positives and the increase in deaths
that you're seeing
are an unvaccinated individuals that's
why getting the vaccine
is so very important nevadans the best
time to get your covid19
vaccine is now it's today
the vaccines are our best tool to fight
covid19
the clark county commission has
reinstated the mask mandate
in an effort to help slow the spread and
i am supportive of this measure they
have taken
while we continue our efforts to get
more nevadans vaccinated
vaccines are how we end the pandemic how
we protect our communities
and we how we retire our masks for good
if you recall 16 months ago
when we started dealing with the covet
19 pandemic
all we had for tools were these masks
some hand sanitizer
and i asked people to cough into their
elbows if they had a sneeze
that's all we had today we have a
vaccine that we're talking about that is
so effective
it's 95 percent effective in preventing
covin so please take advantage of that
just this week i had the opportunity to
visit a boys and girls club here in
southern nevada
the andre agassi boys and girls club
many of the children there were under
the age of 12 years old
meaning they are not yet eligible to
receive the vaccine
the children understood why they needed
to wear their masks
and many of them asked me when they
would be able to get their vaccine
we don't have that answer yet so until
vaccines are authorized for the youngest
members of our community
i'm asking all eligible nevadans to get
their vaccine to do their part to
protect themselves
their loved ones our community and our
economy
vaccines help protect you from covet and
they may help
protect those in our community who
cannot get the vaccine
because of their age or because they
have a condition that makes them
ineligible they're allergic to an
ingredient whatever it might be
through our efforts at the state level
with fema teams
and our local local partners nevadans
have more access currently to the covet
19 vaccine
than ever before we are adding pop-up
sites
every day the micro pop-up sites you're
seeing in neighborhoods
and more information be can be found at
dot envycovitfider.org and with that we
will move on to today's winners
we have invited a handful of the weekly
winners here to join us tonight
but as always they don't know how much
they've won
only that they've won something you
might have won a park pass
you might have won a fishing license but
you've won no you've won a cash prize
i didn't want to disappoint anybody that
much
even though park passes and fishing
licenses are popular and they're good
people are enjoying them so i'm not
taking it away from those winners
in addition to being here at the smith
center i'm excited and grateful to
announce
that the university of nevada reno and
president brian sandoval
and his team have opened up a space on
university campus
in reno for winners up north to watch
this live streamed event tonight
and to participate hello to everybody up
north in reno
i'm excited to announce some of your
names soon
i won't waste any more time let's get to
the straight to it
i have my envelopes ready for the big
reveal
the envelope please here's the envelope
we will start with our five thousand
dollar
five thousand dollar college savings
plan winners
10 lucky students between the ages of 12
and 17
won the 5 000 prize
this week money that they'll be able
this money that they'll be able to put
towards their future
in higher education needs we have
several the winners and some of their
parents with us tonight
our first winner
i'm not doing this on purpose i can't
look full of paper
the first winner is danielle o from
sparks nevada
who i believe is watching in the
northern nevada watch party
congratulations daniel
payton g and isis s both from las vegas
are both out of town but we're joined
here tonight by their parents
to get their award so i hope they're
with us in the audience today can i
see you raise the hands there there
thank you very much we appreciate you
being here
also joining us here tonight and winners
are
gemma m from las vegas
jax b from las vegas
donovan j from north las vegas
and olivia b from las vegas
you want to all come up those winners
that i announced could you come up here
please
is peyton's family here is this peyton's
dad
this one yours can't pull it up put it
in your pocket you're gonna take it with
you though
no they're the next runners
thank you very much congratulations okay
isis s
m
jax b
look at how good he looks in this suit
is this amazing
kind of shame me now my wife's gonna see
that and say he should have won a suit
thank you congratulations
donovan jay another one with a tie
nice job
olivia b
okay congratulations to all
of our five thousand dollar college
savings
plan prize winners now
on to our twenty thousand dollar college
savings plan winners
three students three students
uh 12 years to 17 years old won twenty
thousand dollar college scholarships
and one of those winners was able to
join us tonight for this announcement
congratulations to eduardo p from reno
congratulations
and here joining us in las vegas cali p
has won twenty thousand dollars
kelly oh i don't want to make you walk
i'm bringing the check to you
don't get the crutches in the picture
here that was from that was from a
and now to our top tuition savings plan
winner of the week
this individual one fifty thousand
dollars
that they can use to attend any
institution
of higher learning anywhere in the
country
i hope you choose to stay in nevada but
fifty thousand dollars will go a long
way
towards reaching your education goals
wherever you decide to go
and the winner is brandon b
from las vegas 50 000
[Applause]
brandon
the house said exist 50 000 huh
we're gonna go to school yet you know
okay just think about nevada okay
and now to our cash prize winners
this week's 15 cash prize
winners range from 1 000 to 50
000 all these nevadans had to do to
qualify
as is the case with everyone is get
their kovit 19 vaccine
and you're all automatically entered is
just that easy
we have ten one thousand dollar cash
winners with us this week
including
vanessa a from las vegas
ashley p from las vegas
sarah m from las vegas
francisco r from las vegas
cindy lou kay from carson city
l from henderson
theresa g from boulder city
and kathy b from las vegas
congratulations to this week's one
thousand dollar winners
and cash prize winners this week
yes that's good round of applause
this week there are four 25 thousand
dollar winners
and one fifty thousand dollar winner
three of these big big winners are
joining us tonight
please come to the stage when they
announce your name
winning 25 000 in cash prize
r from las vegas
clay g
there you go
[Applause]
how's that feel he's excited
and from henderson selena
k
and also from henderson nevada
cindy n
okay congratulations
our other 25 000 cash winner
is michelle s from las vegas
that leaves our final weekly cash prize
winner
a drum roll please
there you i like that
their fifty thousand dollar cash prize
winner
is johanna c from reno
[Applause]
johanna you're up in reno but i think i
can hear you cheering all the way down
here
johanna and her family are on the
university campus at unr
congratulations and you can expect a
personal phone call from me in the next
few minutes to congratulate you on this
congratulations to all of the vac day
max nevada day winners we've got five
more weeks of prize drawings
including the one million dollar grand
prize drawing
on august 26th so there's still time to
get vaccinated
and get entered every vaccinated nevadan
is automatically entered
please go get your vaccine it's the way
we can beat this virus
and get entered into next week's drawing
thank you and we will see you all next
week thanks for joining us tonight
sure okay we're going to call the winner
in reno from the podium
so she's watching she should be ready
well you got a lot of envelopes here sir
no joanna if you're there this is going
to show up as a no caller id so just
don't be don't
hang up on me here
hello johanna
congratulations you are our 50 000
winner
well we couldn't be happier for you i'm
glad you got the vaccine i'm glad
everyone
is getting the vaccine but a special
congratulations
on winning 50 000 can you find something
to do with all that money
good for you well congratulations we're
all very happy for you
hello to everybody up in reno that's
watching on our live stream
and remember oh i hear the excitement
back there
remember get entered for next week's
drawing go on get your vaccine tonight
or tomorrow everybody
thank you all god bless you stay safe
thank you joanna okay bye-bye